have seen hides we've seen lows we've
seen extreme drug use women partying the
guy used to be homeless ladies and
gentlemen sing it if you know the words
this is Hans Kim
[Music]
thank you
I I think it's kind of [__] up that
girls will get mad at you if you try to
have sex with them after they do their
hair and makeup and put on a nice outfit
because that's when they're the hottest
like I can't [__] you when you're the
hottest I have to wait till you come
home tired wipe off your makeup put on
an old t-shirt
that's when Hans gets his turn
these [__] they love cuddling
the less circulation there is in my arm
the more love they feel
if I'm ever in a UFC fight I'm just
gonna lay on the dude's arm for 15
minutes
and tell them about my day
I love the ladies I think it's uh sad
that sometimes I have erectile
dysfunction during sex like this guy
it's very hard but it does make going
through TSA a lot easier
do your worst boys
how can I feel you violating me when I
can barely feel the love of a woman
all right thank you all right Hans Kim
so wait you have erectile dysfunction uh
yes is that true I just sometimes don't
get as hard as I want to go
uh what does that mean exactly like you
can you can you can get hard but just
not as hard as you like yeah and it's
not as quick there's a lot of like
you know manual labor oh yeah I think
you have to say manual labor after doing
that you've already painted the picture
completely is that the cocaine I mean
that's one of the things with cocaine
that's what I've been blaming it on
recently so you're back on cocaine no
but she doesn't know that
oh I see
okay
so sex with them after they get ready
that's an interesting
um premise is that a thing that you
actually do I do try to do that a lot
but what we found out about you in the
past is that you're just trying to have
sex with your girlfriend literally all
the time is this still the case no she
brings a lot of her friends over and uh
so I can't [__] her when her friends are
there that's true you cannot [__] her in
front of her friends I'm glad that you
figured that out my sweet sweet Hans
uh so you just bite your time and then
what happens and then I'm like hey uh do
you want to take a nap real quick ah the
old Korean nap
uh we know about this
yes indeed okay so then what happens so
you go to your bed you you then what
happens Hans and then I uh I'm like I
could give you a massage and then I give
her a massage Korean massage everybody
you can't even make it up what else do
you do math problems come on
I love it what else is going on in life
Hans
um I uh recently went to Zilker Park and
uh invited a bunch of comedians we did
karaoke at Barton Springs ah what'd you
sing uh Hey There Delilah okay can you
give us a little example of what that
sounds like you guys have that you guys
know that one one two three four
laughs
Hey There Delilah what's it like in New
York City I'm a thousand miles away but
girl tonight you look so pretty yes you
do
Times Square can't shine as bright as
you
you I swear it's true
Hans Kim everybody unbelievable that was
actually impressive absolutely adorable
adorable
massages and karaoke folks you can't
make it up that was so unexpected and
beautiful that's what happens that is
just our first
comedian of the night this is like a
Love Fest
all night long baby we're not like Hans
we're gonna stay hard all night am I
right
[Applause]